OKAY, THIS YOUNG INVESTOR WHO
JUST BOUGHT A DRUG COMPANY THAT
MANUFACTURES A MEDICATION--
>> BOO!
>> Larry: YOU KNOW WHO THIS
IS, THAT HELPS AIDS AND CANCER
PATIENTS AND GUESS WHAT HE DID.
>> ONE TABLET OF DARAPRIM USED
TO COST $13.50.
THE DRUG MAKER RECENTLY
INCREASED THE PRICE TO $750.
>> Larry: $750.
THAT'S ALMOST AS BAD AS UBER
SURGE PRICING.
I MEAN, GUYS, LOOK, I KNOW
EXPLOITING AIDS AND CANCER
PATIENTS FOR PROFIT SOUNDS LIKE
EVIL IN ITS PUREST FORM--
ANYWAY.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
BUT WHAT DOES THIS C.E.O./FUTURE
BATMAN VILLAIN HAVE TO SAY FOR
HIMSELF?
>> THE PRICE THEY WERE PRICING
IT AT--
>> $13.50.
>> $13.50 AND YOU ONLY NEEDED
LESS THAT 100 PILLS.
SORE THE PRICE PERCOURSE OF
TREATMENT TO SAVE YOUR LIFE WAS
ONLY $1,000.
>> Larry: DID HE JUST ADMIT TO
EXTORTING PEOPLE TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES?
I MEAN, YES, PEOPLE WILL PAY
MORE THAN $1,000 TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES, DOUCHE BAG.
I'LL PAY MORE THAN $1,000 TO
PUNCH YOU IN THE FACE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
RIGHT?